[Musik]
lässig entspannt
morbider charme des zaren und des
sorgerechts
oder es hat die perle am schwarzen meer
mitten im krieg von dem sie sich nicht
aus der ruhe bringen lassen und er doch
allgegenwärtig ist
die gefahr geht mit der zeit aus der
luft sagt der bürgermeister
die größte herausforderung und bedrohung
sind die rakete die luftangriffe auf
unsere kritische infrastruktur und die
stadt als ganzes mehrere zivilisten
wurden schon durch russische raketen
getötet
[Musik]
immer wieder luftalarm immer wieder
russische cruise missiles im anflug auf
das stadtgebiet sie haben sich daran
gewöhnt und das leben muss weitergehen
und doch bereiten sie sich darauf vor
dass russische truppen vielleicht doch
einmal durch ihre straßen marodieren
jeder auf seine weise
das ist ein molotow-cocktail das glas
sollte dünn sein bier und weinflaschen
eignen sich dafür ganz gut
wenn sie kommen dann schmeißen wir sie
auf sie aus den fenstern und von den
dächern
das funktioniert recht gut
alexander hat sich kurz vor dem krieg
eine edle weinbar aufgebaut und er
handelt mit ukrainischen beinen die er
für völlig unterschätzt hält das
geschäft sei seit beginn des krieges
dramatisch eingebrochen viele seiner
kunden die eher zu den wohlhabenden
gehören hätten die stadt wegen der
ständigen luftangriffe
verlassen er selbst hat seine frau und
tochter nach bulgarien geschickt er aber
werde bis zum ende bleiben für sein
geschäft und seine zukunft kämpfen die
in europa sieht aber bereits einen
frieden mit russland
die sache ist doch ganz
nach diesen gräueltaten in mariupol
lucia ihre pin gibt es nur eine
schlussfolgerung
wir sind nicht durch all das gegangen um
irgendwelche konzessionen oder
kompromisse zu machen was unser
stadtgebiet oder unsere lebensweise
betritt
eine niederlage gegen russland das seine
zukunft zerstören wolle sieht alexander
noch nicht einmal in betracht
russland aber ist dabei die lebensadern
der ukraine zu zerstören immer wieder
angriffe auf das schienennetz oder häfen
wie hier in mikolajki odessa und dann
ist da die seeblockade mit der russland
die ukraine vom schwarz meerzugang
abschneidet mit dramatischen folgen für
das land für die ganze welt
25 millionen tonnen getreide lagern in
den letzten ukrainischen tipps helfen
die lager schon jetzt zum bersten voll
und die neue ernte steht kurz bevor
50 millionen zusätzliche tonnen erwarten
sie in den nächsten wochen und niemand
weiß wohin damit
die situation ist sehr sehr schwierig
alle unsere häfen sind blockiert die
millionen tonnen getreide die auf den
schiffen und in den hafen silos gelagert
sind können nicht ausgeführt werden die
ganze welt versucht dieses problem
gerade zu lösen aber die lage stabil
weil die häfen über die bislang etwa 80
prozent des getreidehandel sleeve
blockiert sind bleibt noch eine
bahnverbindung nach rumänien
die einzige brücke über den erster fluss
aber wurde gerade von russischen cruise
missiles zerstört jetzt bleibt nur die
straße ins donaudelta
wir sind unterwegs nach reni einer
kleinen grenzstadt an der donau 400 km
sind es etwa von odessa knapp sechs
stunden fahrt und schon weit vor der
stadt wird das ganze ausmaß des problems
klar
über unzählige kilometer lkws am
straßenrand voll mit getreide und
sonnenblumen
das ist ein desaster hier wir wollen so
schnell wie möglich weg und nach hause
aber die situation in unserem land lässt
es nicht zu
also bleibt uns nichts anderes wir
werden sehen vielleicht wird es ja
besser und die blockade an den großen
helfen wird aufgehoben und wir können
wieder hinfahren
mehr als 8000 lkw die darauf warten
entladen zu werden sind hier an der
grenze zu rumänien gestrandet so
offizielle schätzungen genau weiß man
das nicht in jeden tag werden es mehr
für die lkw-fahrer finanziellen
problemen sie werden nur bezahlt wenn
sie abgeliefert haben die hygienischen
bedingungen katastrophal keine toiletten
die camping dusche gefüllt mit
donauwasser und vielen gehen die
lebensmittel aus
wir sind ja schon seit drei wochen
wir leben wie obdachlose
obdachlose haben vielleicht sogar ein
besseres leben als liefe
der kleine donau hafen in reno und der
mitte des flusses ist die grenze zur
europäischen union am gegenüberliegenden
ufer liegt rumänien
der hafen und seine lager und silos
waren seit vielen jahren stillgelegt das
geschäft hatte sich nicht mehr gelohnt
hektisch wurde der hafen den letzten
monaten wieder in betrieb genommen doch
für millionen tonnen getreide und
tausende lkw es reichen seine
kapazitäten nicht im ansatz aus und auch
die frachtschiffe die es soweit die
donau hinauf schaffen sind viel zu klar
eine alternative zu den tiefs häfen oder
mikolaj sei der kleine donau hafen auf
keinen fall sagen sie hier
meiner meinung nach sollten alle die
jung und gesund sind rausgehen und
kämpfen für die ukraine
jeder muss tun was er kann und ich fahre
eben lkw so ist unser leben in
odessa bereiten sie sich auf eine
russische landungsoperation vor und nach
einem schnellen ende der seeblockade
sieht es nicht aus im gegenteil
wir haben seit beginn des krieges damit
gerechnet dass sie kommen wir verstärken
und befestigen unsere anlagen jeden tag
russland wolle sie wirtschaftlicher als
nation vernichten so sehen sie es hier
und nur ein sieg würde das verhindern